rise and shine it's an espresso time
good morning relief nation it's even my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe in that amazing gift you have
inside to you that needs to be shared
with the world so let's start the day
off right together grab your cup of
coffee and sit on today's message try
new things
over to you louis c.k well I never keep
trying what like stand up is always this
the standby for me like that's what I do
the meal ticket that's yeah that's
that's what I am I'm a comic I'm a
comedian so anything else I do it's like
if I if I make a movie I would never say
I'm a filmmaker
I've never call myself that I'm a
comedian who made a movie you know I'm
definitely a comedian yeah I couldn't
say that one thing with confidence but
so I've tried TV and I try it and it
doesn't work and then I go back to
comedy and then if something I'm doing
is a stand-up leads me back so like hey
this might be a show then I'll try I'll
try anything that I think might be good
I don't care about like well I failed at
it before you know what I mean
who cares try it again I mean I love
that plastic well all this time I did a
pilot the very first time I got a deal
to do a pilot for a sitcom yeah I wrote
it and they really liked it and it got
close and then they said we're not gonna
make the pie I was st. Louie no I was
before that uh whole other thing
and then I made I wrote st. Louis with
this other guy and they made the pilot
we got to shoot a pilot was so excited
and I shot a pilot and then they said
we're not gonna make the show all right
third time around made a pilot and got
one season of lucky Louie on the air and
then that's all they wanted there's
limit to everything that you can't think
everything's just gonna be everything
forever yeah that was the limit of that
one I did one season okay
and now I've done Louie and it's I've
gone three seasons so I'm got a little
further each time I push the ball a
little further ahead each time I mean
not doing something because they don't
work would be like if you're a
quarterback and you go to the line of
scrimmage at the 25 or wherever the guy
ran it to and you hand the ball off and
the guy pushes it eight yards and you're
like well yeah the score a touchdown
let's all go home right I mean there's
no point but at the same time will and
really junior the founder of the Wrigley
gum company
started off selling soap and you wanted
to have a free bonus set any time
somebody bought soap they get a free
gift and he made that first free gift
some baking soda every time you buy some
soap you get some free baking soda what
he found was people like the baking soda
so much they kept asking him for it then
he said I'm gonna be in the baking soda
business and he got rid of the soap he
stopped selling it now he was in the
baking soda business you still like that
idea though having a free sample keeping
out every time somebody bought from him
so with every package of baking soda
that you bought he give you some free
dump and the same thing happened people
like the gum so much they decided to get
out of the baking sort of business and
just sell gum and the Wrigley gum
company was born
you can almost never predict how your
business is going to be successful you
look at any company that you look up to
and love and respect and say these guys
I want to emulate that kind of impact
you look at the first business plan and
you look at where they're at now it's
almost never a direct correlation
there's elements of it especially like
the founding mission what we're trying
to do the problem we're trying to solve
but the execution of it changes multiple
times as you grow up and build your
business if I look at my youtube channel
I never thought I'd be doing top 10
rules to success the most kind of iconic
series on this channel it started off as
a test it started off making one video
and the video did well
I loved it great I love to consuming it
myself it's great that you guys loved it
as well and I thought ok I could
probably make one video a week on this
it make it a weekly series 52 people a
year is probably enough to be able to do
right and it became so popular I thought
we did two to Foley we could probably do
two people in week one hundred people a
year it gets but it's probably doable
and I ran them on Saturdays and Sundays
and then as they gained more popularity
you guys kept leaving feedbacks I love
this how about this person how about
this person how about this person and
pretty soon we had to 3,000 requests
with different people to do we're
keeping track of all them and ever know
and it's like became the biggest task
for the people my team they keep track
of all your requests and I thought we
should go daily we have enough like
there's enough people and that became a
five time a week thing and it still is
now so what started off as some tiny
little experiment that they didn't know
if they would take off or do well became
a cornerstone of Howard
in my channel I'm constantly evolving
and testing new series even within a
series testing the formatting in the
layout and how we bring the content to
you guys it's important one one because
it's fulfilling if you're not expanding
if you're not growing if you're not
trying the things you get bored and as
an entrepreneur boredom is is the death
sentence we hate being bored you want to
go off and trying to stop bring that to
your business instead of looking outside
to do something now stop worrying about
a side business or something else bring
that energy into your company if you're
bored of your business you've got to
bring more of you to your company and it
all starts from experiment from trying
new things from seeing yes you could be
William Wrigley selling soap so then
selling baking soda if it's only gum in
the gum of the thing that these you are
if you look at Ferruccio Lamborghini the
guy who started Lamborghini he was in
tractors and he bought a Ferrari and you
went to Enzo Ferrari the founder Ferrari
told them your engine is amazing your
engine like the Ferrari engine is second
and unlike it's the best engine ever but
the rest of the car the handling like
the rest of it here are some suggestions
and I think you can make your Ferrari
car better if Ferrari told him you stick
to making tractors and I'll make cars
and in Lamborghini got so upset by that
that he said okay I'm gonna be in the
car business and that's how Lamborghini
was started so you went from making
tractors to making the highest of high
performance cars you never know where
your business is gonna go what's
important is that you have that mission
you know what you're trying to create
you're trying to create an emotion of
positive impacts on how in the world
helping your customers do something
right like your founding principles
values your one word bringing that into
your company but the execution of it
will change likely multiple times one
just has a reaction to the market like
you thought something work out but it
didn't work out you had to make
adjustments basically what your
customers wanted and - you're gonna grow
and change your ain't just won't be the
same as they are in 10 years you're
gonna grow you're gonna have new
interest you're going to want to
incorporate new things into your
business and so it has to be a constant
evolution constant looking at what you
are excited by with what the market
wants and the plan will continue to
evolve
never have a perfect plan it doesn't
mean don't plan have a plan and then
start doing stuff start executing and
you start adjusting so don't be afraid
to try new things and that means you're
gonna fail a lot
most things won't work out most of my
new series that I launched don't work
for every top ten that I've launched
we've had five to ten series a didn't
work and that's okay it's part of the
process you learn it's part of the game
I love everything that I made I love all
the series that didn't work out but you
guys didn't so we cut it and that's fine
that's part of the process it's not
absolute failure it's not like oh that
didn't worry about something that I'm
gonna quit and give up you keep trying
to keep experimenting and by again doing
those little things trying those little
tests out it fills you up that
creativity needs to come from the work
that you're doing daily not for some
side thing that you're doing what are
you doing daily and then you can match
it to what your customers want sometimes
so the question they today is I'm
curious what is the most recent
experiment that you ran in your business
that maybe you just launched and you're
hoping is gonna work out or maybe got a
few fact that didn't work out or the
next test you want to launch I want some
creativity some tests showing up down
the comments below share your
experiences I would love to hear I also
want to give a quick shout out to rod
Pinder Rob thank you so much for picking
at the top of my book you one word
really really means a lot to me man and
I hope you do so thank you guys again
for watching I believe in you and I hope
you continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
event special
they spray so give me go
I had a little trouble with sushi girl
because I read it and I thought wow this
is awfully violent even tortures someone
with with pliers to the teeth and I've
been married to a dental hygienist for
over 30 years so yeah it's made the
philosophy with you with her but I
thought this is one of those movies that
I would like to see I don't know if I
could handle being in it so foolishly I
turned it down and and my daughter said
you know you're always complaining about
why don't I get parts like Paul Giamatti
or why don't I get parts like Steve
Buscemi because I love those character
parts it doesn't have to be the main
role just something interesting in
supporting is fine with me so she said
if you turn this down I don't ever hear
you complaining about not getting
character parts again I thought boy she
right I wonder if it's too late and I
called my agent and said contact them
and say that I want to meet with the
director and fortunately they hadn't
cast that part because as it turns out I
mean I didn't know anybody in the cast
except for Tony Todd and he has such
gravitas he's such a great actor and I
was sort of his sidekick so I thought
well at least I know Tony and but it
turned out to be you know one of the
most fulfilling roles I've ever played
and I didn't expect that first of all I
believe that most people there's really
only a few key areas where we have
almost like a superpower okay um
aptitudes all right I guess we could
call it a super aptitude and we're
looking for those super aptitudes all
the time by trying out different lanes
alright so take myself I'm somebody who
has attention deficit disorder and what
that means is that I can speak almost
indefinitely it means that I also have
almost infinite creativity and that also
comes from growing up with depression
when you're depressed that could
oftentimes trigger this very very
intense creativity so between having
depression and attention deficit
disorder and also in my case if you look
at things like growing up unable to read
social cues you have an interesting
recipe for how I build real social
dynamics okay so I basically found my
super aptitudes because by not
understanding something so thoroughly I
had to break it down so deeply to
understand it that's social dynamics
which creates great content plus of
being depressed creates creativity and
also having a didi allows me to talk
forever because I don't feel the passage
of time in the way that a normal person
does I can't feel time passing so I
could do this forever okay so if you
look at that that created a super
aptitude okay now how did I find it I
tried out many different things as long
as I was trying out different things I
was happy so tried out one thing tried
another thing try to know the thing try
to another thing try to another thing
we've we've established the fact that we
love to play everything you know like
there's not us
there's not a genre that were that will
shrink from but at the same time I think
we've just gotten very confident as
songwriters to the point where if we
want it if we want to try something we
will you know we're not hesitant to try
something even if it sounds a little
sweeter like you take a song like Saint
Marie that's on the new album and it's
got a very cool California country vibe
to it you know ten years ago maybe we
wouldn't have had the stones to be able
to do that you know and now we're like
we're gonna do whatever we want you know
so it's you know it's it's a that you
know the the strength of experience and
yet still having that refreshing love
for music that encourages you to try new
things raise your standard Apple cool
its core value is that
not one drop of myself work depends on
your acceptance of me
I don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or absolutely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten most a success I have a
very special secret video for you these
are the individual clips that I have
personally learned the most from and
applied to my life and my business check
the link in description for details